by describe it as having bubblegum and
once it's lost all its flavor you have
just a piece of rubber that you chew
over and over again that is essentially
what food is like for me when I put food
into my mouth my name is agent Malik and
I have lost my sense of taste I suffered
a cold and I started getting a metallic
taste in my mouth
once that finally left took my sense of
taste with it it took me a few weeks to
actually identify that it was my taste
because I could smell perfectly I only
eat foods now which spend very little
time in the mouth because I don't
extract any flavor the idea of a
chocolate bar or a steak the way you
chew it in order to bring out the juices
and the flavors of it there's no
enjoyment from it so I find myself
eating very light foods like salads and
rice and also I used the advantage of
adding herbs in order to make the smell
sensation quite enjoyable I also find
its spice very important spicy is not
actually something you taste it's
something you feel it gives us that sort
of tingle in my man you end up with a
rather peculiar eating pattern that
people look at you funny because you're
putting chilies on your breakfast cereal
and you've put in a a mustard sauce on
pretty much a lot of the food you eat
and almost three years now we're still
not otherwise rooster why it's gone or
getting my sense of tastes back
it's like my world is washed out and I
see fewer shades of color than most
people do so normal people see a million
colors I may see as many as a hundred
million my name is Wendy I'm a producer
at CNN and I am colorblind my name is
Maureen Seberg I'm a tetrachromats
and I'm an author tetrachromacy is the
presence of a fourth cone class in your
retina
if I keep naming my invisible colors
maybe I'll have my own Crayola box one
day when I was in kindergarten my
teacher called my parents because I was
coloring the leaves of my trees and the
trunks of my trees the same color
because I couldn't really see the
difference between green and brown the
only time it was ever overwhelming is a
paint contractor came to my house and
brought no fewer than 32 samples before
I was satisfied that it was a true beige
when I pick out clothes that's hard I
have been known to buy the outfit that
the mannequin is wearing because I know
that that goes together you don't want
to go clothing shopping with me because
the salespeople tell me but it matches
and I can only look at them
sympathetically and keep looking I never
think like oh if I weren't color blind
it would be so much easier to get
dressed in the morning it's just it's
kind of part of me I guess I'm a unicorn
or something
I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
just because I've always been an artist
and it made it much easier for people to
be able to understand it
my name is Willis McCracken and I am a
synesthetic
artist synesthesia is a neurological
condition where your brain is basically
cross-wired
so certain stimuli will come in and
it'll create the wrong response in my
brain so from me that's listening to
music and it's translated into color in
my head I'm going to paint superstition
by Stevie Wonder I love the song
superstition just because it's dynamic
and funky and just fun and expressive
whenever I start a piece that you listen
to the song first to even know what kind
of colors I'd like to use there are some
songs that I hate that I'd like the way
that they look a little bit like a lot
of pop music it can be pink and purple
and you know just all these fun bright
colors but songs not that good so one or
the other I appreciate it somehow you
know you kind of really have to be in
the right vibe to be able to paint if
you're not in the right vibe you're not
going to make anything good I think the
prettiest onra of music is jazz music I
love blues and golds and whites and it
just seems very pearly and iridescent a
little bit when I listen to Etta James
at last the thing that stuck out most to
me was just her voice at the very
when she goes into the last
then it's just a very bright and but
also warm sort of feeling and very kind
of classic jazzy which jazz music
generally has a very gold and blue sort
of look to it music has always been a
very big part of my life my older
brother is very musical and when I think
back of him playing the guitar for me I
think of the colors of what those
memories are I was always a little
disappointed because I was never very
musically inclined it was really cool to
have a way to bring music into you know
my life in a different sort of way
what is synesthesia everybody who has it
experiences it in different ways so I
asked a handful of people from around
the world about their experience so
somewhere in my brain the senses get
mixed together when I experience one
I'm also experiencing another that is
completely unrelated what do you mean I
color code numbers in my head so ever
since I was a child I was able to taste
work if I'm in physical pain I
experienced the pain in color and shape
sounds melodies and in fact sound tracks
also has a color to me so what sort of
associations would you make
number three is blue number three is
light blue three is yellow number six is
a flirty woman four is green two is red
42 is green red that's my favorite
number because I like the colors red and
green together but wait it gets weird
for example I love flesh dance songs
she's a maniac is blue one for me but
what a feeling is yellow word our people
taste is like meatballs in tomato sauce
violins as may be blue rectangles moving
from right to left the word English
taste is like a slice of lemon the sound
of a banjo taste is like Oreos crazy
right but a life without it hmm my life
without synesthesia I don't want to
imagine more empty less would be a lot
more blue world would be very flat and
not as colorful I would be bored smell
we know when it's good and we know when
it's bad but there's a woman in Scotland
I'm joining them who can smell the
unsmiling all my nose went on fire joy
Milne is the only known person who can
smell Parkinson's disease I have an
extremely sensitive sense of smell
I can smell it
meanly on the forehead and the back of
the neck to Joy it has a greasy musky
odor it is just a heavy smell to me she
first noticed it on her late husband les
Milne 12 years before he was diagnosed I
just thought he was tired and he wasn't
shouting enough
it wasn't very welcome of course me
saying to mug you're smelling it wasn't
until she attended a conference with
other Parkinson's patients that she
realized the smell was something more
when I walked into the room I saw gosh
these other people smell the same as
last us at the end of meeting my stood
up and said why were they not
investigating the smell of Parkinson's
no-one was investigating because no one
else could smell it researchers set up a
controlled experiment to test Joy's nose
she was asked to distinguish a set of
t-shirts worn by those with and without
the disease she insisted one of the
subjects in the control group had the
musky scent the man run about eight
months later and said I've got
Parkinson's so I had pre diagnosed
somebody by the time most people are
diagnosed 80 to 90 percent of the damage
is done
so Joy's mission is to help scientists
improve early detection methods if they
can find these people
earlier it would stop this anguish that
would make such a difference
so there's a direct correlation between
tastes and sight you see something that
looks delicious your mouth begins to
water you see something sour you pucker
but what about sound as it turns out
sound has a direct effect on how your
food tastes Oh hungry
this concept is being studied by
Professor Charles Spence I'm an
experimental psychologist and a gastro
physicist the research is in two parts
part one we've found that although one
hand people match music and instruments
and pictures of sounds to different
tastes and flavors and food and drink so
listening to a musical scale you might
say from this twizzler tastes like in a
note and these pretzels taste like a G
note and part two we then play matching
music that corresponds to what you're
tasting you can use that to bring out
and actually change people's experience
of sweetness of flavor in the food and
drinks that they are consuming just like
you can pair wine with cheese Spence
says that you can pair music with wine
Tchaikovsky's string quartets
low-pitched sounds kind of rumbling
Vitamix better to sort of a heavy red
wine to bring out business whereas
Mozart's flute concerto it's a much
better match for certain white wines
showing that we can bring out the
sweetness he actually calls it sonic
seasoning and while music has now been
proven to accentuate flavor
it can also dull it loud background
noises actually dull are salty and sweet
taste receptors think about that next
time you served peanuts and pretzels on
an airplane souls of the sweet taste do
tend to be suppressed by that background
noise the one flavor scent however
that's not impacted umami this is savory
think tomatoes
'if carrots soy would eat on the
airplane it's amazing how many people
order tomato juice and Bloody Marys the
umami taste is one that is not
suppressed by loud noise like the sound
of the engines rumbling it's an
interesting concept and in the very
least the next time you go out to eat I
guarantee you'll pay just a little more
attention to the music that's playing in
the background